Hezbollah calls for day of rage over
Gaza Hospital blast so the story there
with the hospital blast is a is disputed
right now all the leftists are basically
saying Israel uh uh uh destroyed with a
with an air strike a hospital killing
500 civilians however it is being
disputed many on the right or more
pro-israel are saying because it's not
just the right or the left but
pro-israel is saying this appears to be
a rocket misfire from from Hamas and
based on the footage I I can't tell you
I'm not an military ordinance expert or
whatever rocket expert it does look like
first you do see a rocket emerge from
Gaza and then in the middle of the air
it sputters out in a strange way and
then all of a sudden directly below it
you see an explosion it looks like it
may have been a misfire the rocket then
falls from the sky and slams blowing up
on the hospital but I don't know I don't
know for sure it's possible that um an
Iron Dome interception uh hit it and was
deflected and was invisible I mean I'm
I'm not being CED I'm saying had no
Trail no rocket you so it was at night
and for some reason you couldn't see the
Iron Dome rocket it's possible but my
understanding is that Iron Dome
interception uh uh which are Rockets
themselves you can see both there's that
famous photo of the Rockets coming out
of Gaza and then the uh the Israeli Iron
Dome flying up and intercepting them all
so when you see this video and a rocket
goes up sputters and then Falls straight
down it looks like a Hamas misfire yeah
and and I think
yeah and you're right it's it is a
little difficult to discern so we
actually we actually have a video here
it's it's super hard to see you can't
really see much you follow it right
here and then it just bursts in midair
and then directly below
it I don't know if you can actually see
anything you see the you see the bang oh
directly
below
I I I'll say this
though the two stories it was well the
leftist arguing was an Israeli air
strike but that video shows something
not many people are arguing the time
stamp doesn't make sense or whatever
okay fine I don't know whatever I don't
think I I think it would make more sense
there there is a post by someone who's
not an official with the Israeli
government saying that they hit a
hospital a terror a terror group using
hospitals a base deleted the Tweet
Israel saying No this appears to be a
Hamas misfire I think The Simple
Solution here I'm not trying to give
Israel a free pass Hamas is firing a ton
of rockets that are makeshift made out
of water pipes like that the misfiring
is extremely likely and probable if
they're firing thousands of them yeah
look I'm not uh an ordinance expert but
if that video uh is correct you see it
in
ascendency and then you see something
yeah a burst and then something come
down so air strike certainly it was not
right I mean well but but assuming that
video is of the question some people are
arguing the time stamp is off we just
don't know this is modern fog of War
where we we're dealing with propaganda
where you've got the left in United
States just I mean a really great
example of this fracture would be uh and
I haven't watched it but Hassan
and Ethan Klein have a podcast together
and Ethan is married to a a woman from
Israel I believe she's from Israel and
she was in the IDF and Hassan is an
American leftist I'm not sure if he was
born in the US or or you know because
he's Jen huger's nephew and Jen was born
in in turkey in asemble but uh the
fracturing there where Hassan is like
Israel is bad you know and then Ethan is
trying to be like but can we at least
acknowledge what Hamas is doing is wrong
it's like the left is fractured on this
one completely in the United States The
Divide is so Stark that if I mean look
the us is going to be paralyzed if it
tries to fund intervention on behalf of
Israel because you've got a large
faction of the Trump supporting base
which are going to be like not a chance
and the entirety of the woke left not a
chance so you're going to have perhaps a
plurality but maybe even a minority in
this country who would agree with some
kind of us involvement in the region and
that's that's going to lock us out
they're going to have to just go ahead
and do it but that's risking
destabilization in this country yep
that's why I urge everyone when I see
these videos to remain suspicious of of
anything that confirms any bias you
might have for this conflict because
people are reporting on this stuff
immediately or tweeting about it
immediately and they're like they seem
like they know exactly what it was I'm
like we've been through Co you know
we've been through a lot of things a lot
of lies in our generation it's like I
can't trust anything and you we don't
see we don't see videos coming out of
Ukraine like this ever I just want to
say right now the truth matters to us
morally yeah but in this war it matters
none Hezbollah is calling for a day of
Rage he said the hospital strike was a
massacre and a brutal crime and even
though Israel is saying that it was a
Hamas M misfire all the Arabic nations
are saying nope you did this it doesn't
matter what really happened it matters
the Israelis aren't calling for like a
day of
Rage I know that but after they go into
a Cabots and kill men women and children
the Israelis weren't saying let's have a
day of Rage all over the world and the
point is but that's they the fact of the
matters in this Hospital strike are
immaterial to what comes next the left
will accuse Israel they will rage
because of it whether it was true or not
well what's interesting too though is
remember last week we had the thing
where um whoever it was Hamas was called
the Hamas guy the ex the former Hamas
guy who was in Cutter yeah he called for
the day of jihad on Friday and you
notice how there wasn't a day of jihad
on Friday that's because these things
take time to plan like you have to
organized something like this they
organized this massive attack for years
they organized you know 911 they
organized when they commit these Mass
atrocities so you know I think one thing
to worry about is like have they are
there more things that are organized you
know like we're not going to see a day
of Rage necessarily unless what we're
seeing in Jordan and Beirut right now
when when you get when you get a call
for a day of jihad on the Fly they say
hey this Friday you get two days to plan
and nothing happens I'm not surprised
but now that those people have been
activated by the news last week are now
seeing this now they're going to be
mobilized more more likely so there's
embassies burning right now you know
right it's I think something's happen
and people are saying that there were
pockets of violence on Friday but the
media has refused there was protest and
riots the guy in California who drove
through the crowd uh that they were
saying well there was the guy in
Brussels who killed people the guy in
Brussels guy in Brussels uh and the
teacher Paris I mean Hezbollah also they
weren't just saying that it was the
hospital that's their reason for the the
day of Rage they said that it was a an
unprecedented day of anger against the
enemy and its crimes against Biden's
visit to the Zionist entity to cover and
protect this criminal entity the message
should be clear that this is a day
without turning back on the path of
resistance Victory and retribution for
the oppressed against the oppressor so
what they're also saying is it doesn't
matter what you ever do we are going to
fight until we annihilate you yes well
and look this is an adage we've all
heard but it is absolutely true if the
Arabs decided to disarm tomorrow you
would have peace if the Israelis did you
would not have a Jew left in Israel
right and perhaps the world like yes I I
mean it's and the Palestinians have
never missed an opportunity to miss an
opportunity right every single time
there's tried to negotiate some type of
two-state solution they have missed an
opportunity every single time something
real has been put on the table which
makes you think they don't want peace
right and if this was some kind of pan
Arab movement then why don't the
Egyptians and the jordanians and
everybody else open up their borders
support them try to do something they
don't want them well they value their
own culture they don't want that I want
to pull up this tweet I just saw Andy no
retweeted it Gio confirmed uh appears to
be stating that it it this does seem
based on geolocation data to have been a
Hamas rocket which uh for some reason
misfired fell down onto the hospital you
can see two explosions and uh they
actually go through the Geo data they
look at this this is this is really
amazing investigation pulling up uh uh
daytime photos and then comparing it
with the with the news footage so you
can find the locations multiple videos
of the rocket here here's a better a
better video in the last one you can see
kind of what happens to the rocket going
up and then for some reason in midair
there's perhaps a misfire reasons
unknown and then of course you can see
the de two detonations on the ground so
uh look we don't know for sure but take
a look this is really amazing they've
got land markers showing what they
appear appear to be the same thing they
believe the geolocation data the
coordinates are all there the buildings
they've identified and they show the map
and I believe it looks like their
conclusion is uh a missile launched by a
Palestinian group exploded midair for
reasons unknown and one piece fell onto
the hospital causing an explosion the
geolocation and timing of the footage is
conclusive more information will be
added to the thread this is from three
hours ago so a really interesting thread
uh they're saying it's conclusive I'm
still saying I'm not entirely sure but I
I do think this thread is particularly
interesting if you want to check it out
geoc confirmed on Twitter and I would
say this look and as I said I'm no
expert but I have looked at a number of
these things just through my previous
work uh in the
government to me that looks like and you
got to remember a lot of these are
homemade um Rockets Rockets right so it
looks like the Thruster probably broke
through the actual shell and then that
thrust pushed out the side of it and the
a lot of these Rockets cuz they're
homemade they're kinetic that means it
has to touch
it with force to be able to go off and
they're usually in the nose of this
thing and so the Thruster probably burst
out the side of the actual rocket and
then it fell down make kinetic contact
obviously with the hospital and that's
just a guess nobody quote me out there
try to Own Me On it later but it's just
a guess you confirm mentions I mean the
simple version is what you see when the
rocket ignites in midair is the
propulsion system breaking and the
payload is still active when it slams
into the ground exactly because those
are the payload itself
generally they're kinetic right and so
if the if the if the rocket and the
booster go out then it's going to
wherever it falls it will explode look I
mean this is this is the scary reality
of War this is what false flags are for
a nation historically this has happened
several times will attack itself because
they they can use that attack as
justification look up the years of lead
in Italy it went on for decades they it
was just was just false flags on each
other the whole time uh and a lot of
people blame NATO I think it was was for
interfering with that and planning those
false flags and little little historical
tidbit is in the very beginning of of
the years of lead and if the the rumors
of NATO being involved are true the
person in charge of that group was
General lender who was the guy who went
to JFK with operation Northwoods but
there's always been the question
question too of don't forget the war in
the Balkans right where you had the
shelling of the market which uh they had
blamed on the serbians and then it was
like well actually was that the kavars
that had actually done that there was a
question around getting us involvement
going after that shelling uh who
actually had done it um not saying I
have the answer to that but that was one
no matter who did this though and there
if there were 500 people in that
hospital it's a war crime yes and it's
disgusting no absolutely it's disgusting
but it is you know and we talked about
this at the outset it's very interesting
is all militaries have always had scups
right you know propaganda and things you
know trying to push them you're trying
to push messages and scops and trying to
push uh the population in the manner in
which they think about a conflict in a
certain direction but today it's so much
different because it's like to second to
Second you know this you know World War
II right or Vietnam where he had scops
it was over a long trajectory period of
time right of trying to control the
narrative now it's just almost chaotic I
think that we're in a non-reality I
think we're Beyond reality right now I
keep calling it post reality and it's
like that that's like the totality of
events occurring both digital and
physical right as as the whole world is
on fire that's a great term for actually
post reality working on that I'm trying
to get it started so it's like the share
modernism postmodernism reality post
reality we're Beyond because because
watching people debate decapitated
babies on Twitter within moments or or
or ghost of Kiev you know crazy thing
about those debates is that it the idea
is that in some way if you can I say
that there's this kind of propaganda or
that kind of propaganda on one side or
another then that justifies your opinion
or perspective on the conflict and it
doesn't like propaganda Warfare is
propaganda Warfare it doesn't really
have anything to to do with what
actually is objectively going on I want
just point out real quick uh one of the
super chats Justin SLA says Max
Blumenthal has proven it was Israel I I
checked ma Max blumenthal's uh Twitter
history and I I've not seen any any
definitive information or anything
proving anything simply I have seen some
conjecture that the videos that are
putting out have an incorrect Tim stamp
which will have to be verified and I'm
also stating I am skeptical on the geoc
confirmed but I do think a long thread
from a geot tring with coordinates uh uh
non-war non-journalistic entity is just
being like we tracked the images we
looked at the the locations here's the
coordinates it's it's reasonably more
likely to be true however I I I will
remain skeptical I I don't know who did
this but it does seem in my opinion
based on everything I've read Hamas
likely had a rocket misfire I mean look
these are these are makeshift improvised
Rockets yes saying that that misfired is
not unreasonable saying that Israel with
military Precision blew up a hospital
full of children that's a bold claim
that requires some B some extraordinary
it's possible it's entirely possible
entirely possible yeah I mean this isn't
like a patriot battery firing it's like
you know those things don't miss fire
right they go where they're guided to I
mean but Hamas like you're saying it's a
makeshift rocket I mean I think it's or
it's Iranian right don't the Iranians
did it either either way the the you
know Israel is operating with I think um
what the fourth strongest military in
the world they said I mean this is this
is this is Cutting Edge this is bleeding
edge weapons technology there can be
accidents there can be mistakes it just
means the probability of the accident
mistake is going to be on Hamas not in
Israel that's right and and and you know
look there was a statement put up by
someone saying that it was they said
Israel struck a hospital that was
operating as a terror base or whatever
and then the person deleted the tweet
that didn't mean anything to me I I I
don't know right we don't know for sure
that's what's so weird is like any
reality you want to be true is will be
true for you on the internet you just
got to find it right everything you want
to be true is true which means then
nothing is true you you can you can
always product too of like the the
relativist approach to everything where
it doesn't matter what the perspective
is everything is is equally valid which
is essentially not just post reality but
post morality which we are definitely a
postm moral and and even though these
things may or may not be true we are
learning how people are reacting to what
they think is true which is also
terrifying you know because there some
people want this these things to be true
no matter what side it is well and the
crazy thing too is you have like the you
know so many people who are walking
around carrying trans flags being like
I'm Pro Hamas and you're like you you
know they would kill you they right they
hate you as well as me they don't hate
you less because you says in L with my
the that they are they are certainly a
death cult yeah definitely a death cult
going on I think it's like
um they're they're the inversion of
logic right and I'm not trying to be
funny like you H how LGBT for Palestine
I mean that's it's releasing criminals
and arresting victims in New York If you
defend yourself you get arrested and if
you're a criminal you get released it's
it's it's Bizarro world it's it's an
inversion of what logic is cuz there's
no more distinction between parity and
reality and
yeah there's no distinction between good
or bad because both are equally valid
depending on how you feel at the time
exactly so when people first saw Alex
Stein doing his routine I standin dude I
love I love it but people on the right
thought he was a real person from the
left hilarious so there there's no more
distinction which is is funny but it's
insane I feel bad for the Babylon be
they try yeah but it's like they're more
prophetic right I mean they can't do
much at this point because you'll see
what of their headlines and you're like
oh but I just saw that in the Washington
Post I know just Blends in it's the same
yeah that's that's so that so they made
not the be they made life has become so
absurd they have to make it's not satire
but it seems like it sounds like it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time